salve youtubers e benvenuti ad una nuova
recensione
siccome era da un po che non toccavo
questa categoria ecco a voi il ritorno
del versus e si ritorna dalla cyrus me
sentivo la mancanza
chiedo scusa in anticipo per il naso
tappato ma purtroppo torno dalla piccola
influenza quindi mega python versus
gatorade mi ha sempre incuriosito questo
titolo perché mega python e guarda caso
un mega pitone va bene ma gatorade quale
magica creatura astrale sarà mai con
incredibile fantasia e di ispirazione
degli autori è un coccodrillo un
coccodrillo coccodrillo ma basta se devi
fare un film trash con delle creature
giganti perché sempre il coccodrillo
il bello dei film trash a basso costo e
che può aiutarci detto quello che vuoi
buttaci che ne so una lavatrice gigante
con tre zampe un gigantesco piatto di
fusilli al sugo con quattro braccia o
sarah jessica parker giganti insomma
trash al cento per cento
no deve essere un coccodrillo
coccodrilli sono josé ma lanciamoci a
capofitto dentro la trama e vediamo se
questo film riesce a intrattenere il
film inizia con degli animalisti che
dopo aver liberato dei serpenti da
quello che credo sia un laboratorio
scappano dalla polizia come spegnendo le
luci e nascondendosi dietro un albero
ok questo avrebbe sicuramente funzionato
se non si fossero messi proprio sotto
una fonte di luce e furbi ma la volante
che era ben due metri da loro
magicamente non li vede e li sorpassa
perché appunto fare le leggi della
fisica e della realtà di questo film
sono come quelle dei cartoni della
warner
chiedo scusa per nessuna ragione
specifica la volante torna indietro
cerca di seguirla di nuovo ma si ribalta
dal nulla
siamo a tre minuti dentro il film è già
mi è venuta voglia di andare a vomitare
due volte non è un buon segno
arrivati sulle sponde di un lago getta
di serpenti in acqua la mattina dopo
vediamo un cacciatore e il suo cane
buffa incappare in uno dei cosiddetti
mega python
chiedo venia buon uomo ma lei veramente
va a caccia con un fucile d'assalto è un
m16
a parte il fatto che è illegale ma non è
un po troppo e come chiamare la svolta e
lev di ai per salvare un gatto
incastrato su un albero
facciamo la conoscenza di terry un
promiscuo sceriffo e il dipartimento lo
ha confermato gli alligatori sono
diminuiti e perciò non ci saranno
permessi
aspetti io i soldi con me e chi prima
arriva meglio alloggia
e io sono arrivato per prima abbiamo il
diritto di cacciare gli alligatori
terrazza di dialoghi sono ogni tanto mi
arrivano delle mail molto simili tra
loro dove mi viene detto che si i miei
video sono carini e divertenti ma non ho
le competenze per parlare di dialoghi
origine vero per l'amor di dio ma non
credo serva una qualche qualifica per
capire che questo tipo di dialoghi e voi
non potete cacciare a meno che non
vogliate andare in prigione
no non voglio andare in prigione fa
schifo la dottoressa di prima quella dei
serpenti liberati raggiunge questi
cacciatori intenti a sparare dei
serpenti
facciamo un serpente un grosso serpente
e dove sarebbe questo grosso serpente o
per cui nei miei pantaloni a mi sembra
più un piccolo lombrico vuol vedere
meglio la grande anaconda piccolo verme
ok battute sulla grandezza del pene
erano proprio divertenti negli anni 90
infatti il film del 2011
fantastico assistono all'attacco di un
alligatore da parte di un serpente
riesco a m 20 sul suo cabrillo lo farà a
pezzi è il suono che immette prima di
sferrare l'attacco fa venire i brividi
i brividi addirittura mi sa che sto
guardando un film diverso da tuo dopo
questi avvenimenti viene riaperta la
caccia vengono ritrovate numerose uova
dentro un container certo avreste potuto
rompere le uova anche senza sparare
magari risparmiando i colpi per qualcosa
o guarda che coincidenza
sono proprio contento che argeneau
sappia sparare ti meriti di morire e gli
altri dunque uno viene mangia tissimo da
un coccodrillo un lato invece riesce a
far fuori un serpente
e rimasta incassato sotto il cadavere
ammetto che questa scena mi ha divertito
dovrebbe essere una scena drammatica è
nata ma non stiamo a sindacare messaggio
direbbe una mano sono rimasto incastrato
sotto il sette per cento delle risate
però liberatosi dal cadavere si ritrova
circondato da altri serpenti giganti per
lui è la fine ma l'occasione di salutare
per l'ultima volta la sua tiffany
age sono qui amore il nostro sarà ma
cosa stai dicendo
e questa si merita il premio come frase
più imbecille che abbia mai sentito in
una situazione del genere perché dirne
una bugia fiber morì nella illudi così
nel nostro sarà potevi dire qualsiasi
altra cosa qualsiasi di solito ci sono
due alternative o le dice una verità che
non si è mai riuscito a dirle non mi è
mai piaciuto grey's anatomy lo guardavo
conte soltanto per fare sesso dopo
oppure il classico dei classici la fai
sentire amata ai delle tette enormi si
sono cliché ma sono molto meglio di una
bugia che i fan year j quindi partono
alla ricerca ma vengono attaccati
è appena passato la scena orribile o
solo io l'ho vista
ripeto non ho le conoscenze per poter
criticare gli effetti speciali però
l'orrore
da quel che ho capito hanno messo la
pelle del serpente fatta al computer
davanti ad una carne fatta con materiali
veri da cui hanno fatto uscire la radio
john carpenter sarebbe fiero di voi
ragazze ovi ucciderebbe a padellate
dipende
ma qual è il piano per sconfiggere i
serpenti darò la caccia al serpente
stanotte come come pensi di farcela con
dei grossi allegato
un [ __ ] genio per sconfiggere una
creatura gigante serve un'altra creatura
gigante devo dipingere una parete grande
ci vuole un pennello grande logica e che
cosa si mangia con dei grossi allegato
oddio gonzi la sonata capacità aiuto io
una soluzione usiamo la creatura ancora
più grande
ma veramente un'idea del calo libera del
kraken
vuoi un grosso coccodrillo però
procurerò e tu signora che ha recitato
in una puntata di scrubs non le dare
corda sisti tutti scemi
siccome i coccodrilli sono ancora troppo
piccoli
secondo voi con che cosa giganti ranno
bene dacci subito quelli anabolizzanti
altrimenti sarò costretta ad arrestarsi
per possesso illegale
metti tutto nella jeep degli
anabolizzanti piano brillante sarà una
buona idea creare alligatori più grandi
che mangino i pitoni l'equilibrio della
natura deve essere ristabilito ok e hai
ragione è proprio così che si
ristabilizza pompando i muscoli dei
coccodrilli il cerchio della natura
prevede anche di farli partecipare al
mister olympia e posare per calendari si
trovò un cazzo di genio ed è tempo di un
montaggio video completamente inutile
devo dire che la musica è azzeccatissima
per il tipo di immagini che vengono
fatte vedere è complimenti
uno studioso assiste ad uno scontro tra
titani e decine di andare a riferirlo a
terry senza risultati ciao ho sentito
che cosa ha detto si limiti a scopo gli
animalisti trovano lo scheletro di un
serpente quando all'improvviso dio
quello quello in no no non puoi
seriamente aver fatto diventare i
coccodrilli grossi come treni merci con
degli steroidi il loro per scappare
vanno in acqua vanno in acqua buon dio
il vostro quoziente intellettivo è lo
stesso del retro del mio frigorifero uno
viene mangiato dalla computer grafica
scadente l'altra viene salvata da una
scaletta e da una scena in green screen
intanto due cacciatori in barca morite
il mondo invaso da pitoni e coccodrilli
giganti e tutti vanno in acqua e la
stessa stronzata che succede in tutti i
seguiti dello squalo dove ogni singola
volta succede attenzione attenzione
non entrate in acqua c'è uno squalo
ripeto non entrate in acqua pericolo
mortale passo e tutti puntualmente vanno
in acqua
prendiamo della dinamite un'ottima idea
quella non è dinamite quelli a una bomba
ad orologeria ma dovevate pescare un
faro un attentato
fatto sta che con un colpo di scena c'è
ha dell'incredibile vengono attaccati
si no
certo occhio ma la dinamica e non era
nella sacca dentro la barca come ha
fatto ad esplodere dentro il serpente
e siccome non sono un esperto chiedo a
voi è giusto come reazione umana che
dopo aver visto un suo amico farsi
esplodere dentro un serpenti gigante lui
si beva tranquillamente una birra come
se gli fosse morto il pesciolino rosso
no strano mentre terry da una festa per
celebrare il parco cosa che fanno tutti
quando hanno un parco infestata da
creature infernali riceve una telefonata
dal cercatore che ha trovato mille mila
uova di alligatore mandi via tutti gli
ospiti e chiami la guardia nazionale ma
lei non vuole sentir ragioni quindi
metterci di guardia per non farlo
entrare
cosa inizia il gioco rj
ok ora ne sono sicuro sto diventando
sempre più stupido ogni minuto che passa
a guardare questo film
neanche il mio cane così stupido
cattiverie cattivo cuccia ci si mette
anche l'animalista che ha le prove
filmate di terry che a napoli dei
coccodrilli e volano parole grosse
faccia da coccodrillo o brucia ti farò
strisciare come serpente cerca gatti che
litigano odio sto film
ed ecco che arriva la cavalleria i
coccodrilli insieme ai pitoni cosa
perché adesso sono alleati cos'è
cambiato
a tutti quelli che hanno un'arma la
tirino fuori adesso
perché tutti hanno un'arma dovrebbe
essere una battuta su come tutti gli
americani abbiano un'arma non ho capito
dobbiamo resistere fino all'arrivo della
guardia nazione fazzoletto brutte
notizie amico mio la guardia non verrà
terry credeva che tu stessi esagerare ma
stai scherzando
no
ok scherzavo lancio la bottiglia perché
una molotov è fatta in casa dovrebbe
esplodere
qualcuno mi spieghi qualcosa il mio
cervello si rifiuta di collaborare
mi serve una vacanza è l'inferno si
scatena in città
cacchio finalmente si vede un po di salo
trash
era quello che chiedevo dall'inizio
un serpente ingoia un treno un serpente
in gloria un treno o è finita qui potete
mettermi di end e io sono contento ma
purtroppo continua io devo sorbirmi
battute come sempre commerciali ei saldi
davvero mostrato cosa dovrei fare lì
sotto ci rido sopra
non lo so sguardo morto e passa oltre
riusciranno le nostre eroine a salvare
l'insalvabile o come spero vivamente
verranno mangiati e sputate per terra
per porre fine a questo delirio vogliono
mettere dell'esplosivo nella cava delle
uova guidare un aereo per irrigazione
con del feromone dentro attirarli e
farli esplodere ma nella tradizione
quando guidi un aereo c'è sempre
qualcosa che te lo vuole mordere
tieniti forte siamo 3 nascondere
scelgo rimane incastrato e terry come
neanche ben gyver saprebbe fare si
ingegna per portare le creature della
cava wow qualcuno che finalmente usa la
testa
ecco questo è un colpo di scena intanto
della cava le uova si schiudono
l'animalista non riesce ad uscire in
tempo per invece sbaglia le tempistiche
ed entrambe si ritrovano incastrate
insieme ai mostri donne
lasciatemelo dire siete inutili terry il
casinò è stata tutta colpa tua e non sei
riuscita a rimettere a posto nulla
animalista tu invece non l'ho ancora
capito che schifo di senso ai sei stata
buttata dentro il film solo per dar
fastidio
siete lì inservibilità fatta personaggio
dio santo qualsiasi cosa qualsiasi cosa
sarebbe stata più credibili di voi
signore e signori ecco a voi le
incredibili avventure delle gambe delle
sedie
vi meritate soltanto la morte è un
triste sorriso
ticket
parola faccia quel serpente stanotte
come come pensi di farcela con dai
grossi allegato quindi questo era bega
python versus gatorade posso dire che
abbastanza inutile soprattutto la prima
meta la seconda è già meglio ma è
comunque molto noioso se siete riusciti
a divertirvi con un film del genere di
temi come perché io
dicevamo